hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
still addicted to fortnight Battle
Royale yeah yeah me too
over the last week I've been trying to
find relatively safe areas to land with
loot chests nearby I've tried to use
double chests as a starting point with
another chests close by you may find 1
or 2 people at these locations but none
of these should be overpopulated and
each of these will have you stocked up
ready for the mid-game fights and the
late-game madness so here are 6 great
landing locations for chests and safety
my first location is at the dirt track
on the right hand side of the map and a
potential double looped chest over by
the cliff edge is a viewing area
overlooking the track on top should be a
weapon but underneath can yield two
chests if you are lucky from this point
you can venture over to the house on the
other side of the track and pick up the
potential new chests inside or better
still have the drop on anyone who lands
there another good idea is to check the
track for ammo and consumables as it is
completely littered with bullets which
will be perfect for the endgame
shenanigans continuing west leads to
another building to loot usually with no
one in sight - so this 90 second run can
yield 5 chests on a good day but keep in
mind it can also yield absolutely
diddly-squat
just above the wailing woods is a
weeping willow tree which looks quite
secluded and stands out from the other
trees in the area at the base of the
tree can be to loot chests and although
I've only ever received one it's still a
great place to start from here head
north to a lonely Shack which has a
chest in the basement from here you can
travel west to these houses which have
chests in the rooms and one in the
basement too I would have made this the
starting point for this loop run but I
found two or three people quite
regularly land here so going to the
weeping willow should keep you out of
the fight if you want to avoid these
potential people further go east instead
to the ice cream truck on the hill to
more treasures can spawn here the key to
this landing location is the ability to
move east or west to move closer to the
storm and avoid confrontation if that's
what you want to do there's a freaking
brilliant spot in moisty mire which has
a potential to drop three chests even
though it's named on the map I hardly
see anyone go here slap bang in the
center is a huge hulking tree with loot
chests galore
if you're lucky accost I find sniper
rifles here regularly and that is a
great weapon to use here due to the mire
bogging down other players who run
through it just south of this spot is a
tree house which can hold another two
chests so potentially five chests in one
minute also make sure you check the
wooden structures around as there's some
pretty good booty to top up your loot
chest findings oh and even check in the
tree husks to occasionally really good
stuff the next one on the list is
getting a great deal of attention at the
moment but when approached correctly it
really is excellent the tunnel are under
passed below tomato town tomato tomahto
tuck whatever you decide under here are
usually a couple of weapons and two
hidden loot chests - the problem is that
there will be someone else going for
these chests so getting in the tunnel
from the correct side is paramount
if possible enter from the north so jump
towards tomato town when leaving the bus
this side is the closest to the weapons
and usually leads to an easy kill when
the other person enters from the south
of course it all depends on the
direction of the battle bus and if it's
possible to land quickly from the north
anyway you may be lucky enough to be
here all alone once you've made the area
secure grab the weapons on show smash
open the hidden area and fingers crossed
you'll find two loop boxes and an ammo
crate - from here I tend to head north
and take out the person who has looted
tomato town there's also a house just
above the T on the map for another chest
- the caravan park is another great
place to land as it has three chests and
another three or four close by so
potentially seven chests a buttload of
guns and ammo and great links to run -
after looting the area that many people
do not utilize it's found in between
retail grow and lonely lodge there's two
ways to do this either land on the barn
roof and smash down to collect the two
chests or my preference land on the
outskirts and pick up weapons as soon as
possible just in case you're not alone
it's a ton of guns and ammo to grab and
a loot chest or two around the fence
always be prepared to fight another
person who landed on the roof or leg it
if you want to live to fight another day
the route out of here is important as
you can get another four chests head
west past the outskirts of retail row
don't go in there unless you want to
fight check the truck on the roadside
for a chance of a chest from here head
Northwest to the campsite and you could
find a weapon but if you're lucky
slurp juice drops here regularly and to
finish the run another camp site and two
more trucks are here for even more
precious loot
over on the outskirts of greasy Grove
are a few houses to land on aim for the
bridge and swing over to the house and
bond there could be a chest in the roof
of both buildings continue north west
and another house will be here for your
convenience again in the roof another
chest this starting location finishes
with a perfect view point of greasy
grove allowing you to spot nearby
enemies and scout their direction creep
up on them and take everything they've
looted but in fact wait as I was
capturing this footage I stumbled upon
another chest this is the second house
we looted traveling up this hill will
net you one more chest on your run so
four chests in 90 seconds with hardly
anybody around and the perfect vantage
point to choose your next encounter
hopefully from this you'll comfortably
be in the top ten and maybe get that win
too there we have it six great landing
locations which are relatively safe and
always have about three treasure chests
nearby always pay attention to the bus
direction before deciding which is right
for you if you have any other landing
locations which are safe and reliable
please let me know I'll definitely name
check you in the video for your hard
work
much appreciated I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time